all right welcome back it's a variety
show for a good cause we're honoring
World AIDS day today and that brings us
to Golden rainbow putting on an
incredible event every year ribbon of
Life holiday Extravaganza is this year's
event raising money for all the programs
so here to talk about it Gary Costa the
executive director of golden rainbow and
we also have Nick foot the director
choreographer dancer in the show so
first off gentlemen before we get to the
show that's happening on Sunday let's
talk about Golden rainbow and and what
it is that you guys do for our community
sure um we were started 35 years ago by
the Las Vegas entertainment community in
response to the AIDS epidemic that was
going full force at the time they put on
one variety show and to raise money for
for a home for housing and um and we've
been doing that for 34 years and today
we continue to provide housing emergency
financial support for hundreds of Las
Vegas residents with HIV that's
incredible so HIV and AIDS I mean still
something that we need to talk about uh
still you know something that that does
impact our community and as entertainers
and performers you guys no doubt saw
that firsthand so the money that you're
raising for this event is going to
people here in southern Nevada exactly
wonderful and a lot of these performers
who are going to be in the show are
let's say have their day job as
performers on the Strip oh different
shows yeah so we've tried to pick
something from each of the shows you see
the casinos and try to get somebody in
there so we have everything a variety of
everything okay a true variety show so
Nick now you're actually performing in
the show but but putting it on and kind
of directing it tell me what can people
expect I mean people can expect a honest
to goodness anything that you see on the
Strip we try to include into our show
great so we have magicians we have
comedians we have aerialists
um dancers singers just I think the only
thing we don't include is water ah okay
it's just too cold right now so it would
probably freeze so really I mean just a
plethora of different things going on on
stage absolutely where is it and when is
it it's gonna be Sunday okay at the
Tropicana Hotel okay and casino and it
starts at one o'clock great but we have
a great silent auction so the doors open
at 11 and the show's at one okay so one
o'clock at a perfect time so that um
pretty much everyone can get there and
it doesn't interfere with your
entertainers who have to go probably
work Sunday evening so family friendly
absolutely okay wonderful family
friendly and tickets still available
tickets are available and they're very
affordable they start at forty five
dollars right so for you know for Las
Vegas is amazing it is amazing it's
always a fun show it's a family friendly
and it's gonna this is our first holiday
show we've always done the show in the
fall or in the spring so this is our
first holiday show so we've been really
excited to put this one together yeah so
a little bit more elements of um
Christmas Hanukkah like things that are
going on right now to celebrate December
right wonderful is there anything else
that you want to tell Folks at home who
are who are itching to buy those tickets
right now
sure that um HIV is not over yet and so
this money that we raise really goes to
the important cause there are many
people because of covid they've been
displaced from their homes and so we're
trying to find make sure people have
safe affordable housing such an
important event such an important cause
and we're so excited to to be able to
see all the wonderful performers at such
a great price guys thank you so much for
being on the show this morning I know
it's early we'll let you get back to
rehearsals so folks tickets still
available we'll put more information on
our website